he's Ross Tucker former NFL lineman Ross
Tucker podcast host of the new show home
and home on radio.com app Ross thanks
for joining us was there a play that
will stand out ten years from now from
Super Bowl 50 for good or bad yeah I
think without question Dan to me it's
the throw to Tyree kill I mean totally
turn the whole game around if you think
about it the play before
Patrick mahomes threw the ball short to
a wide-open Tyree kill who trapped the
ball they called it a catch they
overturned it and I remember sitting
there thinking boy this is just not
mahomes night I mean it was the worst
I've ever seen him play it was his worst
game ever at that point seven minutes
and 13 seconds left in the game they're
down twenty to ten and I'll give Andy
Reed a lot of credit for the play call
they fooled Emanuel Mosley the young
corner for the Niners he bit up vacated
his zone Tyree kills wide-open forty
yards down the field and the Chiefs head
up score touching half of that we all
know what happened but that that was the
play I mean that was the play of the
Super Bowl by a lot what would we be
talking about today
if the Niners had won Patrick mahomes
and Andy Reed both coming up small in
the biggest moment because if the Niners
had won then the Chiefs wouldn't score
that many points obviously it was twenty
to ten with four minutes left seven
minutes left and we would have said Wow
Andy Reed he's got all this talent all
this speed yet he gets the Super Bowl
can only score ten points can't get it
done and Patrick mahomes you know as
good as he's been his first two years as
a starter he gets the Super Bowl and
plays his worst game ever I mean that
would have been the conversation those
guys would have had to live with that
and wear that until they get back and
you know what's interesting Dan always
talking about it you know like oh this
is the start of a dynasty it's hard man
I mean Drew Brees Aaron Rodgers Dan
Marino they never got back again they
only ever got to the Super Bowl one time
so you don't
know how long mahomes Andy Reid would
have had to wear that if they weren't
able to win yeah I started to wonder
about the philosophy I thought the
Niners had a great philosophy I thought
it was gonna be run the ball keep my
homes off the field and then make put
more pressure on him with every
possession because now he's got to score
touchdowns
the Niners didn't score touchdowns and I
thought that was going to come back and
haunt them it felt like they abandoned
the run it felt like they were getting a
little smarter than they needed to and
you gave him that you gave him a
homestead that opportunity and he took
advantage of it I know we like to credit
but we also love to criticize if you
look at the play calling with the 49ers
is it a big issue for you it's not I
would say the biggest issue I had from a
play calling standpoint for the Niners
was the end of the first half now I
don't mind him Dan not calling a timeout
after they stopped the Chiefs at
midfield
because it midfield you don't know what
your field position is going to be I
mean I you know I'd love to see the
analytics on the score probability there
but the Chiefs almost down the ball at
the one-yard line at that point so if
you call a timeout in your Kyle Shanahan
you might be giving the Chiefs a better
chance to score what I didn't understand
what from a play calling standpoint was
okay the ball went in the end zone it's
a touchback
you got to both the 20 a minute left and
your run on first and second down and
huddle up I just thought how about just
a short pass a screen pass Kittel or one
of the running backs didn't really like
that I'm not as critical of Shanahan's
play calling in the fourth quarter as
some other people are because I mean
they were open you know it's Chris Jones
tipped one pass Garoppolo missed one
pass Emmanuel Sanders was wide open you
know after they got behind they did have
some runs that were successful but you
know that's one of those Dan where if he
runs it on first and second down on both
those series and then third down they
throw is complete Oh Kyle Shannon is too
conservative just like he was the end of
the first half
if Garoppolo hits those throws or Chris
Jones doesn't get his hands on two of
them I think we're all singing a
different tune talking to Ross Tucker
and Westwood
one analyst and the Ross Tucker podcast
also hosted the new show Holman home
yeah but you you also had John Lynch the
GM up in his box who is signaling for a
time out so it's it's not like um and
unless he thought you know man that's
weird he's not gonna let Jimmy try to
get us in field goal range there this is
John Lynch the GM saying let's call the
timeout here so there was a disconnect
between what John Lynch thought they
should do and what Kyle Shanahan thought
they should do yeah and I I disagree
with John and I agree with Kyle in that
instance because when they're putting at
the 49-yard line and you don't know what
your field position is gonna be and you
still have three timeouts
I'm not calling timeout there because
you know it's almost gotten to be like
arena ball Dan where you used to think I
mean and a half oh man this game this
half is over now it's like sometimes
both teams get the ball another time
and I think Shanahan looked at it and
said if they pin us down with the one or
two and we go three and out me calling a
timeout is just giving Andy Reid and the
Chiefs a better chance to score here so
I understand John Lynch is a defensive
player originally and everybody feeling
that way but I'm pretty confident that
if you looked at the probability to
score in that situation that it was more
likely the Chiefs would score at the end
of the half then the Niners what doesn't
make sense is okay it's a touchback you
have it at the 20 you run it on first
and second down you're showing no faith
in Garoppolo at all and then what was
crazy about it Dan is they throw the
ball to rule sin out of the backfield
they get 25 yards they get to the 45
yard line and then they throw the bomb
the kiddo which I thought was a good
first of all it was unbelievable throw
by Jimmy G unbelievable you want to talk
about moments then if kiddo doesn't push
off if he just catches the pass that
might be what we talked about we might
talk about how the Niners scored the end
of the first half that was a huge thing
to go in a halftime with the momentum
and Garoppolo made the throw of the
night it's just unbelievable how many
different little thing is including
kiddo just pushing off
and a little bit make so much of a
difference do you call that I think so
yeah I mean I thought that was faster
but I mean first of all he did twice
second of all when you extend the hand I
mean I know you're a basketball guy to
Dan you know like you can kind of put
your elbow there or you can use your hip
or maybe even put your arm up there but
when you push and extend the hand
clearly they're taught to throw the flag
I thought it was a good call
I thought the officials had a good night
now there was one time where Jimmy G got
rocked helmet the helmet and third down
the fourth quarter that I could not
believe they didn't throw the flag but
other than that I'm glad that the
officiating was not a major storyline
good to talk to you is always Ross we
appreciate your time during the season
and we'll be checking in with you again
thank you
my pleasure thanks for having me as
always dead that's Ross Tucker former
NFL lineman and his new show home in
home on radio.com
that's the radio.com app for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]